nyc the big apple new york city ever
heard of it gang the boys are gonna be
here gotham comedy club november 9th on
the isle of manhattan we're coming back
we're storming the beaches get some
tickets and come see us it's the new
york comedy festival our first time in
it you don't want to miss it the show's
going to sell out also the boys are
going to be in hartford connecticut on
december 14th and we're going to go to
albany new york on december 15th and
then where are we going after that big
man we're gonna be in syracuse december
16th get those tickets
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r.u garbage
it's a little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out
they're growth to be classy or if
they're just a big old piece of trash
you don't say i'm your host dave foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here in aunt tooty's basement she's
mad at me why because i ate her apple uh
donuts okay
this literally sounds like something to
happen in your apartment i'm not gonna
lie
these apple cider doughnuts are hot this
time of year and cody don't mess around
it sounds like antoni's probably your
girlfriend
might have had a tasty relationship a
time or two we're not related by blood i
don't see anything wrong with it gang my
co-host is coming at you from across the
table it's a family episode we're
circling the wagons oh yeah we're
locking the doors we're rolling down the
[ __ ] curtains it's just the fan
blackout season i'm gonna be rattling
off your guys questions we love you as
we appreciate you but before that
the international businessman himself
boss the mogul what are you launching a
space company
these guys are killing you
you're gonna be like 20 years behind i
know i know hypersonic rockets flying
around these guys are bare i'm go i'm
gonna save up to like we can go to deep
space anybody can have space get to the
moon whatever once we're at the moon i'm
taking over
the moon yeah you let them storm the
beaches and then i come up the back make
sure the coast is clear it's all a long
game with me how many two liters of diet
coke and mentos
i don't know but we're gonna figure it
out and with your help we'll get that i
like what you're having with your head's
at kid this kid's a go-getter what's up
gang oh sorry it's kj everybody yeah
that's been big in the youtube comments
and instagram comments and for the
record it's not kj it's k-a-y
somebody early on goes let's set
president real early on it's k-a-y-j
exactly what it is
what's up everybody jewelers
class every kiss begins with kay uh
what's up gang thanks for tuning in we
[ __ ] love you you're the lifeblood of
the show we appreciate it if you haven't
already please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes even though those
numbers don't really [ __ ] mean
anything no more but we're always
flirting around the one hundo mark i
would like to break i would like to
break into the top like 50 or something
you know
uh so you can check us out there and
then full video available on youtube and
as you know those numbers are true
and then i don't have my notes in front
of me do you have to can we we might
have to cut this until i do this to me
every week until i finally don't do it
to me you know i get fired until i find
the great let me google greatest website
of all time that's right it's
patreon.com
patreon.com garbage go check it out
plenty of [ __ ] bonus content on there
probably over 80 hours of podcast you
get it went up 10 from last week look at
this guy well we're killing it we record
a lot of [ __ ] episodes i don't know
what to tell you i heard 70 80 maybe 90.
we do live streams and also people don't
know if you're just tuning into the show
the additional bonus content is on there
we got the cribs of your childhood home
the cribs of my childhood home
we got the golfs on there we got our
moms on there we played ayg with our
moms family friend on there from your
childhood family friend we also got your
first limo ride we're doing it and now
the new the new goal that we announced
is in a couple hundred more patreons i'm
taking a big man and t-bone to disney
world when you wish upon a star it's
gonna be a good time i've also never
been oh my god i'm friends with bizzos
i'll show you the ropes i am not going
with toby
i'm the princess of this trip
big boy let me tell you that right we'll
take you to the dippity-doo salon get
your hair done this is my make-a-wish
right here they whack you out for about
700 at the dippity-doo salon what's the
deputy do sorry go and dress you up like
a princess will take into the cat in the
magic kingdom and they you know they
dress you up can i do that i mean yeah
legally if you're allowed you sure will
pay for it
florida might not take too cold
with you i don't think they need that i
don't think they want a 400 pound guy
around the little gals
he's eating the pumpkin carriage
yeah that's nice it'll be a good time
it'll be a good time to be drinking
around the world the whole [ __ ] nine
yards i love it i appreciate it i i
appreciate you pulling the trigger on
that
it's nice i'm excited to go i'm excited
for it yeah but now because you lived
your whole life as a non-disney guy now
i've always hated it you hated disney
but wait hold on let's pack that up
you've hated that you've never got to go
yes the disney corporation it's good
people and you've projected on people
that did get to go and you're it's like
the it's the classic
immature age foley that thing stinks
you're like yeah oh disney world stinks
it does it you [ __ ] bozo
oh disney world stood your cool rides in
your millennium falcon yeah that's like
that you can't fire me i quit i'm glad i
waited till now because if i would have
won as a kid i would have missed all the
cool [ __ ] they have now can't really fit
on a ride though it's going to be an s.u
i figure by the time you know
have you seen that patreon i think i'm
going to be there next week
i'm gonna have a time share down there
pump the brakes i need a couple of
months to get in disney world we should
go to a timeshare pitch
okay that should be that that should be
part of the trashy trip is that i'll get
a weekend in disney to go family they do
that i'm sure set it up
i'll bring some sandwiches
be nice
go to lunch you gotta watch it you just
have to watch a nine-hour powerpoint on
saturday
is it nine hours they get you they
really wear you down that's what it
works
how are we going to film it go
undercover body games oh yes t-bone
t-bone gets a company card i'm gonna be
there with a cowboy hat with a vhs game
inside
toby's dressed up like a bell boy
[Laughter]
pushing a cart
i like it it'll be a good time i'm
excited thank you get on that patreon
thank you to everybody that signs up i
mean there's over 2 300 now and i think
that goal is going to be 2800 i think
we're doing 27.50 or something like that
yeah we're going to disney yeah we love
it we love you guys we'll do a show down
there too ooh
[ __ ] the big guy planning a big
weekend i like it yeah timeshare pitches
casual dining facilities
[Laughter]
disney buffets i bet they have a nice
buffet at disney i don't know if they
really do buffets there really i don't
know i figured that'd be right up their
alley apparently they'd be serving slop
right at the gate when you walk in
have some more it's got a ladle full of
shrimp thrown in your fat face you're
like an orca
gotta watch out for the gators too and
we're gonna be staying off properly
buffet's pretty good that's the dolphin
food bro
we're gonna be staying off property by
the way what do you mean we're not
staying on desks that's how you whack
you out it's like [ __ ] seven hundo i
want the full experience yeah the full
experience the full the full ryan family
experiences you stay off off the [ __ ]
premises you drive over you're fighting
you park seven thousand miles away hop
on a tram it's a whole [ __ ] sleep in
your car yeah
where's the car b9 remember that hey
maybe if you don't drink so much all day
you'll remember where the car is i might
throw a couple tantrums or two just
preparing i can only once you see how
big it is of a cat like you're a cook
you're walking a lot oh really yeah
we'll get golf cart privileges somebody
already photoshopped us on rascal
scooters
zipping around zipping it yeah i like it
gang how about a nice quick shout out to
our producer we didn't even bring it we
didn't even bring it to you you didn't
you didn't i got disney on a brain
man pitching that patreon i like this
kid's a go-getter i'll tell you that
right now
uh gang is a local bozo he's a good
friend of ours
you may know him as buttons
give it up for tebow mcmuffin toby
mcmurray what's up dudes
dude i can't wait to go to disney yeah
i'm telling you right now you take me
down there can't bring your skateboard
no but what i can do is get about 45
hours of the harry potter experience
that's all i'm filming yeah it's a lot
it's uh i thought you would be against
it against
unhappy no we're not you you troll no i
don't no i listen i was against it i
wasn't ever against it i was jealous is
it different i know but i don't know
i feel like toby's got some kami roots
what are you talking about he was like
homeschooled this kid doesn't know
what's going on he's down there
picketing yeah
yeah yeah big capitalism guy give me
some of that red
bull yeah i didn't know how they had
harry potter too oh yeah they got harry
potter star wars yeah they're like star
wars the avatar's cooking or wait
they have like a wild avatar thing what
is that what do you mean the movie the
rock cameron movie they
where you're like in a helicopter kind
of and you're flying around
and they the whole thing kind of moves
with you but you're like staying still
but like
as it dips it dips
and then like if you could fly over the
ocean they blow in like cool salt air
and you feel it dude and they smell like
you fly over like the jungle and you
smell like grass and stuff it's [ __ ]
they get you all [ __ ] up it's like a
deprivation thing where did you go i go
weekly
no i went a couple of years ago my
family my uh
my mom and step-dad like taking all the
nieces and nephews down every couple of
years could you get mickey mouse tattoos
tattoos yeah yeah we can paint your face
okay i know we said we got to stay off
premises but they're about to launch a
star wars hotel we can sleep in the
millennium field okay come on
come on yo how much that cost dude
like genuinely please it's gonna be like
a ten thousand dollar trip that we ain't
got
we did just set two credit cards on fire
for a new computer sure yeah i mean
i just maxed out two brand new credit
cards so t-bone can go on pornhub or
whatever he does i'll be in disney i'll
be in disney world of ohio
but we're gonna dress up on the plane on
the ride down you gotta do it
you guys what i want to be a pilot no
you wear like your disney stuff you wear
your ears
all [ __ ] up at the bar you just went
generic costume yeah
i'm gonna be a cheerleader
i call construction worker
[Laughter]
[Music]
good stuff for having a good good times
family up kip doing some cues yeah got
some cues guys so as you know when you
do join up for uh the aforementioned
patreon we will answer your garbage
question it's just the best way to do it
but before we get into that i got
something that blew my mind as you know
i got some of my wife's uh german
european friends staying with us this
week
i didn't know we were talking about this
publicly uh no but they brought up
because we were talking about are you
garbage and stuff like that
and then we were talking about leftovers
okay and like you know which is like the
doggy bag to take the leftover box is a
big has been a big
the first probably big issue on here
you're a snob
no i don't do leftovers i finish my meal
that's i'm not a snob it's not like i go
do away with this food i eat my meal i'm
an adult i'm a grown man and also i'll
say again i don't know what reality you
don't finish your meal in okay
but the germans what they do
they take in another level of bonkos
take the chef home with them
hey buddy you're getting a cop hey hans
you're ours now
you bring it nice get the car
scottish that's german all the way i
don't know
i don't know let me get another take
that's the thing about foley he's such a
patriot he can't take any other
you won't get in the car god damn it
that's my german
my australian guy he ain't doing it
i'm australian
so where are you from originally
i thought it was pretty good you get in
the car
that's german i don't know it's a little
eastern uh far east as well
um
no but they it's
uh it's they take their own tupperware
to the restaurant with them
and then if there's
if there's leftovers they'll put it in
there no they don't yes they do wait
wait
i do we just the germans just broke
foley who does what do you mean who does
that's a common practice or your two
friends or no it's a comment i was
talking to are they doing that here
no no they don't do it uh i was like
what's a trashy german thing they were
like we were talking about leftovers and
stuff like oh it was a big one on the
show they go oh what a lot of germans do
is they'll take their own top imagine
roll into the club with your own
tupperware
got lunch ready to go
that's crazy to me if you're walking in
the steak house with warped lids
you got a cool whip container just put
it in here
cool vip
some europe ah yes
ah yes
but it's not cool it's meatloaf it's
really chilly
dude how crazy is that and then i i my
wife said she's like my fat i've nev my
family's never done that but they're
checks so it's you know i guess it's
they're classy people that's what it is
sure no matter where you're from it's
garbage everywhere
that's crazy right because that's a
large tupperware that's not just like
where are you
your purse i guess that's crazy that's
insane to me i don't know i don't like
it i don't i don't like it because it
takes away the um
the classy uh image of europe that i
have now
now i don't know if i should go to paris
yeah
um that's cuckoo right yeah and then
this one's in the same world i don't
know if we ever touched on it but as we
start going to fancier nicer places
we're not eating at [ __ ] applebee's
all the time
this one is sure
uh have you ever blown your nose in a
cloth napkin at a restaurant that's from
al yes i have ah
really ugh i love it that disgusts me so
much that i might never able to use a
cloth napkin at a restaurant ever i love
it oh grab one of those yeah i'll take
it into the bathroom with me to get a
good face wash if i work at the
restaurant i'm using those like [ __ ]
toilet paper
i burn through those
oh man i'll kee i'll keep your linen
bill high that's devastating
yeah i'm bad
love it love a good bar rag too a fresh
one a dry one they're great
absolutely oh man that's no good put
your grizzle in there when you're
chewing it if you gotta spit something
back out i mean that's jammed up that's
one thing that's you're in a
circumstance that allows you you have to
make a call you can't be swallowing
[ __ ] i'll stuff that i won't like
reopen it up and fold it and like put it
on we know how you get with napkins my
friends scrunchie oh man
don't remind me that's a sign of a dirt
bag yeah yeah we talked about it i used
your napkin yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
didn't get herpes thank you i have i
have scrunched napkins everywhere when
i'm eating i know yeah look they look
like happy tissues if you catch my drift
stuff them all on my glass
um yeah i can't uh i can't do that what
else what else irks me especially the
new york diner now
is you get
you get those glasses that are supposed
to be the clear plastic but they've just
been washed for like 35 years they're
all scratchy they're all scratchy and
like cloudy and then they put the water
in there and i look over and i see like
an old lady with like her teeth falling
out drinking out of a cup and i'm like
how many people have drank out of this
cup
and like i just picture like tuna fish
floating in the top i get it you know
it's funny you mentioned i get a fishy
smell sometimes on a glass and i can't
drink the water it creeps me out yeah
well there's some little faint something
in there yeah i don't like drinking the
water that's why i get diet coke it'll
[ __ ] the bubbles of [ __ ] sterilize
the cup i honestly i really i'm not
saying this to sound [ __ ] new money
or anything but i'm kind of over the tap
water at the at the right i don't want
it i don't want those glasses get out of
here with that really bring me a bottle
of spark bring me a [ __ ] club soda i
don't like the bubbles i'm a flat man
still
i'm no bubble he's the last guy i'm a
blue collar guy i'm american working the
last couple places that i work fancy
pants you'll fit right in over there in
europe you commie bastard yes of your
bubbles
please pierre
um last couple places i worked at did
the did the bottles order for the table
in like old wine bottles like the
correct like yeah or whatever yeah those
things are never wise
i mean never so i stay away from it i
don't [ __ ] with the tap water anymore
i'm out
but i'll blow my nose at the table
i'll tell you that right now you draw
the craziest lines
it's nuts it's crazy you want to clear
out and then you fold it up and you yeah
but then someone's gotta wipe down i'm
gonna i come in it's gonna get steam
clean it's gonna get martianized or
whatever they do with it it ain't
sterile though and you nee if your
boogers are somewhere that that thing
needs to be sterilized okay
we gotta [ __ ] you they gotta come in and
chemically peel this room
get fouchy in here oh man your bugs are
everywhere
and i don't like it
uh great question though beautiful gang
let's talk about all forms all four the
good people at helix yeah jumping out of
the bedroom hopping in the living room
all form couches easiest way to
customize your couch get on all form
they're getting in the game and you
won't be sorry yeah uh it's the easiest
way you can customize a sofa using
premium materials at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores they sent us
one it comes it'll write we got it right
over here you can't see it right now
he's beautiful t-bones he's got his feet
up get your feet off the couch get your
shoes off my friends off my brand new
all-form couch
uh call your father i put it together by
myself i was amazed at how easily it
goes together it's kinda bonkers i was
like there's no way i'm going to be able
to do this it's about a half hour really
whole couch put together by myself you
choose look sharp comfy too you can do
it it's all it's all custom you can do
different colored legs different color
this an arm a chaise lounge an ottoman
the whole nine also two if you get a
love seat and then you move to a bigger
place you can just get that additional
section add it on to add it on
it's fantastic big fan of all forms
um
all form wants you to do their part of
exclusive offers discounts for teachers
students military first responders the
whole nine they're taking care of
everybody nice all form also has uh
financing and flexible payment plans uh
so an amazing sofa is never that far
away and they even offer a forever
warranty that is literally forever to
find the perfect sofa check out
allform.com garbage all form is offering
20
off all orders for our listeners at
allform.com garbage do it now
can't let's talk about dad grass i love
that great great you like puffing
doobies you like getting smoked out with
your boys and putting on pink floyd sure
we all do but as you get older you got
more responsibility pull it back a
little bit you got to pull it back a
little bit but you like to indulge you
like to indulge you wouldn't go home and
drink a whole bottle of wine would you
you'd have a glass you'd enjoy yourself
and that grass is primo stuff man yeah
guys it's a legal organical organic
smokable hemp that relaxes your body
mellows the mind just takes the edge off
it really does like you know we're big
cbd guys we've been for years it's
fantastic i do it every day chill out
without getting stones like you're
having a glass of wine like the big man
said i'll have one when i get home i'll
have i'll have a mom grass yeah you pop
you you puff them yeah uh all dad grass
products are federally legal for ages 21
and over and ships right to your door
anywhere in the u.s of a uh whether
you're looking for a new buzz or a chill
way to join an old favorite digress will
leave you in a euphoric mood right now
that grass is offering our listeners 20
off your first order when you go to
dadgrass.com garbage go to dadgrass.com
garbage for 20 off your first order one
more time write it down because you're
probably high that's dadgrants.com
garbage get a haircut do it uh this
one's from jake van damme ever worked on
that might be that might be his real
name i don't know
[Laughter]
talking about a kick in the face
[Laughter]
he's doing a split between two tractor
trailers flying down a [ __ ]
man that's a [ __ ] tight name yeah
jack van damme
um ever worked on your car in a public
parking lot
that ain't a good look if you're doing
that you guys
you got the toolbox out i might have
watched my mom put in a headlight in an
autozone parking lot that's a little
different the autozone's a little
different you're going there i've
definitely done the light out there
[ __ ] marlboro 220 hanging at
everything raining for some reason it's
never a sunny day any time you're at
autozone it's overcast i'm right get out
of there nope yeah press the brake press
it and you say tell me if the light goes
on
hey tots we're in a [ __ ] 88 taurus
all right let's [ __ ] jump this thing
[Laughter]
yeah it's a tough look you see him in
new york all the time dudes that's just
dude's in the it's always weird it's a
full-blown garage in the street well
like something like saturday they're
just doing it they got three four cars
together i know yeah and some places do
that as they're like that's their
business that's their business like hey
i have this corner
i you know we never get the tickets
whatever we just pay the tickets and
this is our kind of little shop
and that's very neighborhoody and stuff
like that
but like there's there's a guy who's
cash business too yeah
they're not talking no no no no no
they're not on the square you know what
i mean you can't swipe
yeah um
there's one guy in my neighborhood just
like no wheels on the car and he's
always over there tinkering like it's
like a broken down car
but it's been there for months
and he's just tinkering sometimes it has
wheels sometimes it doesn't it's never
left and it's just like that those car
guys don't finish that [ __ ] a lot yeah i
don't have the money typically if you
had the money you wouldn't be doing it
on the side of the road you'd be you
know what i mean you'd have a place
typically it's like i'm going to buy
this old thing and i'm going to get it
together
you're never going to do it now that's
coming from like like my step-dad like
i'm going to redo it you know you're not
she's going to be bitching at you in a
couple of months because it's out in the
lawn with a tarp over the hood uh-huh
you're just hemmed up waiting on a
little bit of scratch for a carburetor
or something and those things man those
cars like that when they're hanging
around those things are [ __ ] hornet
magnets
[Music]
you'll find a [ __ ] horn at disney
world on one of those things they are
frightening yeah i don't know if i told
you when i went back when i picked up i
had the montego's at my mom's house for
a long time i went back to get it man
that thing hornets all over the trunk in
the [ __ ] in the taillights they were
i was just [ __ ] i was spraying from
like 50 feet away with raid
yeah it was bad they were everywhere
[ __ ] going to war empty ones too they
were like all tucked in the corners
[ __ ]
that
i might as well be paying the insurance
on that wait what empty ones like david
like had like populated different ones
and there was like already empty ones
when i oh my god
they looked like a scene from star wars
dude they flew out of the [ __ ] out of
the keyhole at me they were already
renovating oh man he's just a city
planner huh he's killing it there's the
queen i think yikes yeah i don't like
that [ __ ] i've done battle with those a
couple times with my dad because he had
a [ __ ] he he had an old mustang that
sat on the side of our garage for a
while yeah and that thing you got a
perfect driveway for a shitty car to be
on that side oh that's beautiful because
it's raised up a little bit
and it's not in the front of the house
it's on the side it's like that house
came with a beat up chevelle
red body with a blue hood
like the front's up on those two little
ramps
so you can get under it those things are
trash the kids are always playing in it
yeah playing family and driving in the
car uh-huh oh it's garbage but yeah
[ __ ] one of those collected it was
like a super structure i'm at a [ __ ]
cvs and a starbucks this hornet's nest
was a [ __ ] bonko yeah yeah we [ __ ]
pulled the car up with the windows down
with like three or four cans of raid
cracked the window [ __ ] opened up
oh man
cleaning house felt like mcnamara
um
i uh we had uh this was not too long ago
this wasn't like the 90s or early 2000s
this was
the show was probably happening and we
had my stepdad had
he had a suburban
it must have been like a 98 like a 1998
and he thought this thing
was like [ __ ] air force one he was
like when nobody was allowed to drive
first of all i'm like dude the paint was
chipping and he had left it for so long
those things didn't age well no suburban
it was though it wasn't even the rounded
edges it was they no it was before they
really made it
aesthetically for like people to ball
out in it yeah it was that's what was
for towing [ __ ] horse carriages yeah
or horse trailers we didn't have any
horses yeah it was for towing that or
[ __ ] go-karts or something like that
this thing went bad [ __ ] quick dude
it had like one flat tire and then like
within three days the other three went
flat it was just sitting there but my
mom's like you gotta [ __ ] move this
thing it was bad news the car with a
flat tire in your driveway this thing
had four flat tires i was sitting in our
driveway recently really yeah not a good
look the home of the the coldest the
people the other people in the
cul-de-sac were writing letters
buddy of mine
uh
new people moved in uh next door to him
they parked a bus on the lawn oh
not like a school bus either it was like
a school bus that they painted
yeah it looked like the partridge family
bush it was all different wow a tough
look
that's not something you take out if you
took it out every day i'd be like well
it's at least not there just if you
drove it to work imagine the hornets in
that thing oh man jesus driving it to
school
those things don't [ __ ] around tripping
balls he was freaking out too yeah cause
that that's right that'll knock the
whole [ __ ] the whole zip code goes
down oh man property value by bio i
remember one door one time this guy uh
in my dad's neighborhood growing up he
had uh
school buses parked in the street like
he like bought a couple of them at like
auction or something guy was real
[ __ ] cocky who's that real out there
and they were like hey man you gotta you
gotta move your buses this is crazy like
you just have three school buses
park like
his prop like his you know is what's he
doing with him nothing who not obviously
nothing people this guy just bought him
to have him i guess he was probably
planning something you know what i mean
i don't know yeah kidnapping a bunch of
kids so
uh do you remember that movie getting a
whole middle school at once trying to
get a stuntman career off the ground
more buses are going to make the jump
you remember jumping out of the back of
that when they do the drills oh man
johnny dude i thought i was jumping out
of a [ __ ] c-130
i had my shoot i threw it first
out the back you felt like a
construction worker you felt like a
stunt man you felt like everything
[ __ ] navy sealed
you got a dog strapped to me with
goggles on
there's a you're strapped to a fatter
guy
go go go
um
why one bus driver was a v an old
vietnam vet too they all were back in
then what do you think that was the only
job that mailman ah he got into it too
man oh yeah
probably hit the ground roll
[Laughter]
head right to the brush now imagine
there's agent orange everywhere you're
like what the [ __ ] first thing you want
to do when hit the ground is clear dlz
what
good luck on that bus if your name's
charlie
he's looking
he's just staring at charlie in the
mirror
those big mirrors
easy does it they're easy does it i'm
gonna go ahead and call you charles
oh
from now on your name's nathaniel victor
that's a good piece of business um so
what happened to the buses oh yeah
uh
did you did you have safeties we had
like you were like could be like a bus
safety when you were i mean rats yeah
but you were in sixth
grade when our elementary school went
first to six and then junior high was
seventh eighth ninth and then high
school tenth eleven twelfth but that's
broncos we went ninth tenth eleventh
twelfth they changed it one that's the
way to go they changed it when i was in
well it was popular they couldn't fit
all in i know yeah
once they built the second school when i
was in like 10th grade or whatever that
they then changed it too
a proper night when you're a freshman
and you see a senior walking through the
hall
man we're talking guys or girls
i was talking ladies but
the boys weren't nothing to shake a
stick at man i was sick in high school i
tell you there was a couple of guys that
were [ __ ] cool as [ __ ] um
but you could be the bus set you were a
bus safety and you had like a badge or
whatever
real cool sig nine
everybody down
yeah i i was tough but fair you know i
mean everybody had to kick up a little
bit too walking around like john c
reilly and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
gangster new york
put another notch on my stick
ah what are you doing there boys
how was that pretty good huh a little
corrupt
taking money from the lunch line oh yeah
hey for sure hey i'll talk to the driver
see if you can stop at your place first
you know what i mean
i'll see what i can do can't make any
promises brandon let me ask you a
question like walking home at night in
the rain huh it gets a little scary out
there how's that gonna make that happen
the bag of big league chew mate made me
look the other way
where'd you get that shakedown time boys
shakedown time kippy's here i don't want
it all just a taste
i'm a fair man at the end of the day
yeah we all got to eat i applied but
they would i never you wouldn't get it i
wasn't
didn't pass the psych exam
or the piss test probably
he'd kicked me off the force
all i wanted to do was be a safety
officer and then kick me off the force
man you were like that mutant in 300
that tried to be part of that
you end up turning [ __ ] snitching on
everybody i know the way i know
raise your shield boy
i started my own private company
i started doing stuff overseas private
contract
blackwater [ __ ] halliburton fat water
fat water kind of stuff
no never a safety guy safety officer the
badges were pretty tight ours i'm not
gonna lie yeah orange strap and a badge
yeah no badge you're just distracted oh
we had the badges yeah they were metal
too back
this was the 80s
west
what the [ __ ] it was the 80s they were
metal
yeah damn could scare somebody one of
those yeah flash of steel on them
everybody up against the wall
all right let's get into some questions
we've been doing questions what are you
talking about oh man you're having a
good time cuckoo today cuckoo bananas
yeah
how things at home low flow showerhead
finally installed
because you're wolfing over there am i
my whooping you got something you got
some flop do you
there's no product you're typically a
product guy i'm usually a product guy
yeah you know it's a little uh yeah it's
a little different yeah you kind of you
kind of look like costanza when he gets
the toupee
really correction i was bold that's what
you got going on right now
it comes out and in real quick you can't
see where it hits your head
i'm in a transition what do you want
from me
i tried to wear a butt butt short sleeve
button down but i got told i couldn't
wear it because i got sweatpants on
apparently sweatpants in a dress yeah
the little cloth just shirt goes real
well with the sweats i thought it looked
better though right looks better with
the sweats what a pair of jeans
it'll make you feel better i'm telling
you they're coming to work listen it
doesn't make me feel better i like our
routine i like i don't know it's our
routine this coming in here
yeah i like it i like how like having my
comfy clothes on and
and coming in and doing the pot but if i
if i had a spot later tonight which i do
not
i would i would have a pair of joggers
on
which or
sweatpants with a mustache
i mean what are we talking about here
threw a monocle on a pair of sweats and
called it a day they're khakis with uh
and sweatpant material they're the
greatest pant ever
the cargo joggers
i mean
you'll be burying me in those
hopefully
later than sooner
didn't sound confident
i mean you know all right um
let's see here
this one has to do with the car and
we've talked about this before but
this is from jeffrey um
will you put the little tree air
freshener on the mirror without
replacing the other ones do you have
multiple
freezers no i can't do that that's a
that's a very
religious thing for me is that you go
get the car washed and then you switch
out the tree but but i want to say now
i am all tree all the time that's the
only air freshener in a car that i would
ever use is that i'm not doing the
[ __ ] the glades that plug into the
[ __ ] window or plug into the fans
they did have these plug-ins for the
fans that was just like a little stick
those aren't bad but when you want power
and you want to feel good
the sense they come up with that tree
company they're pretty good they're on
they know what they're doing and it's
very nostalgic for me like i put a
cherry one of those on whoa i'm riding
around my cousin flow and his [ __ ]
pontiac granddaddy my cousin flo yeah
his name's nicknames flo his first name
joe joe flo joe flow sounds like a real
cool guy flaherty shout out to him whoa
yeah [ __ ] basketball what's up i'm
joe flo flaherty kid was a rock star
back in the day what's he do now uh does
good family whole nine yards he's older
now he's probably like 10 years older
than me
he was my introduction to cool when i
was a kid
you know what i mean see it didn't stick
with my sweatpants
your polo and your sweatpants yeah he
was much cooler than me but yeah [ __ ]
oh all the boys always had trees
everybody trees are big and what i did
for the first time ever as you know i
got the kia brand new 2021 about 6 000
miles on it
um
i
i don't want it to become like every car
i've ever had where like i don't eat in
it i i haven't smoked a bernie in it yet
i've been pretty good
i'm surprised you've held out this long
you we but you we do eat in you
not we don't eat like you can get like
pretzels or something we're not eating
meals we're not going to the
drive-through well we're not eating
sandwiches it's funny you mentioned that
because i think i let you guys have
bagels one time because we were already
bacon egg and cheeses we were driving a
new brunch which i didn't eat out of
respect because we were already late but
that's why i [ __ ] said it that's why
i allowed it because you're already late
all right we're not doing drives we're
not doing like what does the tree have
to do with any of this because do you
know the way you're supposed to use a
tree
oh just slide down that's what i've been
doing and it's not bad wait so you have
the you have the belly
you put it under the seat
you take it you're only supposed to
nah [ __ ] that you're supposed to breathe
now you're supposed to cut the top and
like pull it out like an inch and then
let that and then pull it out after like
a few weeks pulled out again pulling
like i'm telling you i like it in
overdrive yeah i wanted it i'm trying
not to do that because you can never
bounce back from you're also got a lot
of burnies to cover i'm not covering
anything up that's what i'm saying i
don't need i still have my i still have
new car smell which i don't want to lose
either
you know
so i'm trying to keep uh i'm trying to
keep it a little bit you gotta you've
got a lot of stuff you got to fight back
against that's your problem you're b.o
uh that's probably the worst
uh the i'm gonna make a tree for that
the bernies and all the food in there
sure so well not these days we're going
toe-to-toe
i'm going toe-to-toe i'm going to tote
it with the mucinex guy he's in there
somewhere yeah yeah you got a lot of a
lot of bugs under that seat but even if
i didn't i would be [ __ ] full i want
the full blast of it i'm gonna get a new
one in a week or two gives a [ __ ] sure
keep it running tight i'm saying but
you've also never had a car where you
haven't eaten or smoked in it so you
don't know that you don't need that you
don't need to [ __ ] carpet bomb that
thing with [ __ ] black ice okay that's
what i'm telling you black ice and
gentlemen yeah i think i'm a tropical so
i go light green
sometimes lemon i love a tropical you
know what i loved i don't know if they
make them anymore but lifesavers used to
make a tropical pack you remember that
what am i a [ __ ] jerk-off oh and
there you go there was always that one
coconut one in there yeah you get like
two coconut ones in the [ __ ] there there
was like a light like you were in the
island there was a light purple that
would blow your [ __ ] hair back in
that thing oh no where are those things
i don't know what it was but it was
[ __ ] what they got canceled without
top notch
what'd they say
the [ __ ] that tropical lifesavers ever
do to anybody bring them back that's
probably part of the problem around here
gotta be cool again kip yeah this one
right here what's that it's a good
people at roman romen remember how you
used to talk about e.d back in the day
be a whisper with roman
now it's out there it's out there baby
all right taking care of it they're here
to help if you got a problem you got to
fix it if something was wrong in the
house you wouldn't just leave it you
wouldn't just let the the pipes in the
sink just shoot out 24 hours a day seven
days a week you would take care of it
now with roman you can do it in the
privacy of your own home yeah they're
like the national guard for boners right
they take care of it first man on the
line with roman you get a free online
evaluation an ongoing care for your ed
all from their comfort and privacy your
own home a u.s licensed healthcare
professional will work with you to find
out the best treatment plan and if
medication is appropriate it ships right
to you with a free two-day shipping
they're not just spinning them out if
you need it you get it it's easy easy
peasy
uh getting started is simple just go to
getroman.com garbage complete the online
visit
um you'll get everything you needed ship
straight to your door go to get
roman.com garbage right now you'll get
15 bucks off your first month nice
talking cold hard cash 15 bucks for
first month first month it's really time
to take care of your ed and remember get
started today and you'll save 15 bucks
off your first order of ed treatment do
it katie let's talk about those good
people at bespoke posts bespoke posts
cool guys
cool guy stuff that's what they are
they're cool guys and cool gals that
make cool guy and gal stuff and it's
fantastic yeah of course they're talking
about the box of awesome now you've
heard us mention this product on this
on this here program
all right but the falls in season now so
what you want to do is you want to get a
box of awesome get yourself set up could
be outdoor stuff it could be home bar
stuff it could be grooming supplies or
clothes they do it all yeah to get
started just take the quiz box of
awesome.com your answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome they want
to know what you like we're gonna send
you a bunch of stuff it's free to sign
up you can skip a month at any time
cancel best part about it where they get
you each box only costs 45 bucks 70
dollars worth of gear that's screw balls
you're getting twice your money to lose
the money i have to get the box
cool stuff too uh plus with each box of
awesome you're some more you're this is
my favorite part you're supporting small
businesses because ninety percent of
everything that comes in your box of
awesome is from a small up-and-coming
brand you're helping out the little guy
maybe the person that uh like uh you
know puts all that together the curator
really cool yeah shopping these little
small store stuff yeah do things well
made nice so get 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com enter the code of garbage at
checkout that's box of awesome.com code
garbage for 20 off your first box do it
now back to the show
um this one i don't know i we might have
talked about something along the lines
this is from saul haven't had a question
read yet have you ever had a little or
you know also too if you're in the
position now if you were having a
gathering at the house would you run out
of spoons and forks how many do you got
going like what how if you were having a
dinner what am i a [ __ ] catering
company i got four forks yeah four
knives four good spoons
and we have we we we we've been abundant
to plates but that was an amazon thing
they sent us one and one was chipped so
they just [ __ ] send you another bite
yeah they're not sending you one they're
sending a box of eight [ __ ] bezos is
zipping around the [ __ ] solar system
you don't give a [ __ ] i don't know how
they make money
gets out there
um
yeah we we're probably we got like the
one i'm sorry are we talking we're not
talking about my parents we're talking
about my place you're a place though
yeah you're a parent i mean dude you go
look at my mom has like 10 000 forks and
knives my mom could feed the national
guard yeah yeah literally i know and
then i look at mine and there's like i'm
like missing a knife there's like a
mismatched fork in there it looks like i
stole it from a [ __ ] a college
cafeteria i don't know where the [ __ ]
this thing came from are you a little
fork guy or a big fork guy big fork
spoon typically on cereal little spoon
you got a big cereal guy if a cereal go
big spoon but everything else what about
ice cream
a little spoon a little spoon i think i
go big spoon for ice cream little
sprouts would you never say icy cream to
me ever again
[ __ ] cat or your girlfriend please
i'm your boss and i will be respected as
such
how [ __ ] am i ever going to get the
space when i got you saying ice cream
come on i go little spoon for yogurt
yeah otherwise you'd be done in a second
surprise you're not mainline in it to be
honest with you i go soup ladle for
cereal
we've talked about it in the past but i
remember my dad would make a bowl a
tupperware thing a special k dude
my favorite thing to eat cereal out of
is not a cereal bowl it's some other
thing it's an inground pool
how you gonna get the milk in there
huh
yeah tough those things are great mixing
bowl and just crush like a [ __ ] huge
thing of honey nut cheerios i don't like
that i like going to multiple bowls i
like dancing with the devil of a little
bit of more you know
real yeah
keeps it interesting is this one going
to be too too crunchy is it going to be
too soggy will it mix will you mix the
cereals we've talked about this maybe
would you yeah but i always hated it
because it meant there was not enough
left of something so you got all the
crumbs and the dust i love the crumbs in
the nuts no that's not for me what i
like a whole flake oh the [ __ ] bottom
of the cereal box is the best no toby no
what
now this is crazy i'm not a fan stop the
show you think you know somebody
what about me this is i like crumbs at
the bottom this is gonna cause a riff in
the [ __ ] in the bozo army bring it on
i'm telling you right now oh my god my
camera somebody goes i also love the kid
because toby hit my camera and he never
hits his camera
toby hit me that's i thought that was a
universal fact that everybody loves the
last [ __ ] especially sugar cereal you're
getting like eight more grams no
i i don't like that i just want this i
want the cereal as the manufacturer
intended it whole flakes or whatever i
don't need all the [ __ ] it's dust and
then the milk gets milks feels like it's
like sandy water what are we doing oh it
thickens it up a little bit becomes like
a stew i love that
i love that oh man
mixing backcourt doesn't stand a chance
the way you talk about milky
[ __ ] cereal milk
it turns into a stew how is that
supposed to be more appetizing
oh yeah you know that sugary treat you
have for breakfast it reminds me of a
stew yeah nice goulash ooh now you're
talking oola cereal
[Laughter]
um this one this goes into something
that you relatively talk about uh that
you bring up uh like like stupid human
tricks or whatever like you have a
question about that did anybody in your
family do this the double joint can you
pick things up with your toes that kind
of stuff play the piano with your toes
which i don't think we've ever talked
about this is from kemper do you have a
skill like flipping your eyelids inside
out remember that kid whoo that kid drew
with the back of the bus for sure he
didn't finish no
no he could flip his eyelids inside out
yeah and he would just deeply turn
around like what the [ __ ] god damn give
me a heads up if you're doing that [ __ ]
yeah same kid can make himself fart too
jack of all trades if you ask me we're a
ladies man he was he was double jointed
he could put his arm back like that he
could flip his eyelids he could leak
which was i think we
yeah that's [ __ ] that was like
that was like a superpower
i don't think i had any friends that
could do it we knew a kid my buddy
so we leaked you know we went we went
through a leaking phase stop say i don't
first of all no one even says like i'm a
gleeker
we went through a gleaking phase where
we whatever that was going on whatever
what do you mean it was hot in the
streets whatever what are you talking
you know everybody every movie when we
discovered it whatever age it was when
that was going on you remember it was
all life brights and glee yeah
every my mom was gleaking run dmc was
the music on the street
and we were a pack of gleekers
there was joey the gleek
timing of gleek
mikey the gleek and me
jimmy gleekin
anyway my buddy at the time said sure
that he used to go to holy we heard you
don't clean them
[Laughter]
nah man i'm leaking i swear this weekend
he told a tale of a kid that he used to
take the bus with that could do it in a
constant stream
which we all thought he was lying that's
like that's like the richard gere gerbil
thing no fast forward five years i met
said gleeker we're in high school all
right we're all smoked up driving around
click click click click this kid just
happened to be in the car with his mom
getting gas and [ __ ] my buddy freaked
out he's like this is the [ __ ] kid i
told you about and he did it right in
front of us
oh man that was the greatest day of my
life yeah sounds like a great town you
came from
he's now the
mayor and with your help i'll gleek for
this whole city
uh this one's a home run alan uh
did your family do family newsletters
no yeah no no no and if do we not gossip
on phone calls but never a family oh
forget it my mom's back there yapping
like three barbers what do you mean
smoking bernies and talking medical
stuff my mom who's got what who's this
where are they going niecy and my aunt
patty talk probably every day and
they're just i'm assuming just
give me something here did you whatever
oh yeah i heard i haven't heard back i
don't know you had smoke some coffee
into that
yeah it drives my dad crazy she's always
walking around yapping my phone but no
we didn't do that [ __ ] and we would we
would generally make fun of the long
laundry
laundry list that we would get around
christmas time from you know one bozo or
the other what do you mean laundry list
you actually get a paper
no like uh you know when people send
like the what's going on in their lives
at christmas time oh i've never gotten
that really oh like a family update that
comes with like the christmas card tough
to let everybody know johnny's doing
football and tony's doing this and
he didn't do that uh-uh really what
about you
no no no no that sounds like a family
newsletter to me that's what i would
assume we didn't send the people would
send it to us sure but yeah regardless
i'm saying it's called something i just
can't think of it
your christmas card whatever it is i
don't understand what a christmas card
is yeah but i've never received one
picture of the family and then like a
note of what what's going on
on a beach or something you know we put
them all up on our front door
is that trashy the christmas cards we
got from people my mom always taped them
we put them around something yeah nice
yeah
real trash they'd throw them out on the
first yeah
26.
you do that
i don't think so we put them you do
christmas
what the [ __ ] i'm not
you're a pilgrim right what are you
doing
this is maybe the most insulting thing
that's ever been asked of me on this
show
he's got that wooden wheel and stick
out in the yard
what's it called
the magnet that thing you mean no
no he's talking about the old-timey like
you see amish kids hitting the wheel
with the stick
that reminds me somebody i want to do
devils i'm going to order a pair of
devil sticks bring back my [ __ ] my
reign they're going to say double eggs
about to jump on board i got mine on me
um all right this one is from uncle
cracker barrel
[Laughter]
i don't care who you are
get that kid a scholarship right now
that's [ __ ] genius that'll get you
gleaking for sure
[Laughter]
oh
man
how about that
all right from uncle cb
uh did you ever wash a suit in the
washing machine because you didn't have
time to take it to the dry cleaner
holy [ __ ] well let me tell you don't do
it no it's not gonna bat it's not gonna
come out [ __ ] it up so bad yeah never
looks like you're wearing a suit made
out of sweatpants
bad tough look
not good look at all yeah
never you can't do it's not it's not
meant for that and i i'm also not a big
dry clean guy but you got to dry clean a
suit i love a dry cleaning a dry clean
guy if i could afford it and had one
clothes i'd get everything dry cleaned i
love the dry cleaning your t-shirt like
i don't understand i love to get my
teeth dry cleaned i'd love to have that
no i don't keep everything nice and
tight a little starch too first of all
it's a little too tight to begin with
taut fresh crisp so i wouldn't have the
the the forehead lines on my stoma on my
t-shirts
poor headlines you know the wrinkle
lines
you don't call them four they also go
away when you wash it i know but they
instantly i like how he didn't defend
himself no i know i just don't watch it
you showed up today with them already
with it already ranking up no cuz i rode
in the car this is a clean shirt i don't
think so he's right
[Laughter]
somebody's on the patreon they're like
if we could give a seminar on how to
speak fully
i like to lie
oh yeah um
yes
all right this one's from kyle uh i
don't even know this is this goes back
with the th ha this one's from kyle have
you ever brought your own cake to a
restaurant for birthday dinner
okay
here's the thing with that
it's not garbage
it's not garbage the [ __ ] restaurants
don't have [ __ ] whole cakes and if
they do they're going to charge you by
the slice and bang you out
because [ __ ]
uh callahan's or someplace up here did
that
uh we did a birthday for my brother
right there we forgot to get a cake or
something and we're like do you have a
cake and it was like 150 for a [ __ ]
cheesecake
yeah probably eight bucks a slice yeah
[ __ ] crusher i don't think it's
classy it's not classy it's classy
because i worked at nice joints and
classy people would come in for a
birthday dinner and they would get there
early and they would say here's the cake
put it in the fridge we'll let you know
when to bring it out here's the candles
so when you come and take the dessert
order and all that stuff and you're
ready to serve dessert you just bring
that out it's nice i understand i'm not
saying it's classy though i have a
caveat i don't think it's trashy if you
get a private room i think it's
acceptable if you're just at a regular
they're pushing tables together it's
gonna be how many in the back it's got
to be how many people too wait why i
don't understand
what do you mean what's wrong you're
making a reservation you make it sound
like you're coming in off a bus
and it's a half-eaten cake
well if you bring it
[Laughter]
that slice was already out of that cake
god damn bus boys eating the cake back
they only sold me nine donuts i don't
know what happened
um
yeah
i think there's a number of people you
can you can't do that with four people
it's got to be
an event i feel
i don't think if you're having a
birthday dinner with you with like four
like people or whatever that's gotta be
like 10 12 people first of all it's
gotta be a party let me say this
i don't know if i really believe this
but i'm gonna say it
welcome to foleyville
if you're an adult
and you're going out to dinner with like
i don't care if it's six people mm-hmm
the the most classy move is
hey can you put a candle in his dessert
whatever he will just bring him whatever
and put a candle in it it's it's that
single candle that's what i'm saying so
bringing your own cake is i'm not saying
it's trashy but i'm saying it's not
clear the classy thing is to do the
reserved thing is hey listen bring them
the whatever slice or whatever you have
everybody's got something that they do
for birthday real subtle one candle you
know just maybe if you whatever that's
the one that's the classy way to do it
wait we're not talking about singing
happy birthday are we no oh okay because
that's [ __ ] trash yeah this is just
the cake but also too if you're bringing
a cake i'm assuming you're gonna do the
happy birthday
that's that goes hand in hand now hold
on that's what i'm saying if it's a
grandpa it's typically like upstairs at
a [ __ ] irish pub or something if it's
trash if it's a grandpa i've got i'm
flip-flopping on this it's trash if i
was trying to give it to you if it's a
grandparent and there's kids involved
yeah you might have to sing happy
birthday that's a little different it's
a little different i'm saying no you're
saying you're going adults you're going
like five couples
all right six couples 12 people
i don't think you should sing happy
birthday of course not and to me the
classy thing is hey
it's his birthday do whatever you do
superstar don't bring out the happy
happy birthday like just bring him a
cake with no sparklers shooting up
that's two what are you doing unless
you're popping bottles [ __ ] one oak
or something
stalk with straight shots and pop
bottles
um
yeah no it's trash it's trash i've
flip-flopped on this it's trash you
shouldn't do it i mean if you do
whatever it's a good time the separate
room
does give you a little bit more leeway
of like hey this is our space we're
doing our own thing aside from
the restaurant i think you're correct
it's got to be at least 10 people i
don't think there's anything wrong with
it and some of the most classy joints i
ever worked in
with like wealthy people that doesn't
mean they're classy you could all go all
this you say this all the time i'm
saying they weren't
listen i'm saying they work they work
not because they're wealthy
how many that could be ten they brought
in a strawberry shortcake from [ __ ] i
don't know some bakery shop right some
no i'm not talking about a sheet cake
from shoprite i am cause i ain't too
shabby
it's an everyday cake yeah i'm not
saying people don't i don't know it's
not the classiest way to do it put it
that way give me that it ain't the
classiest way to go about it
it's not it's for sure not the classiest
way to go about it classes wait about it
everybody orders off the menu if you're
picking up the bill because it's your
wife's birthday that's what it is you
don't worry about the [ __ ] money you
also don't bring in a [ __ ] sheet cake
from you know [ __ ] the cake boss or
whatever i just thought of something
well hit it hit it don't hold out i just
can't something come over to the dark
side well we recently had a birthday we
celebrated my mother's 70th
happy birthday patty happy birthday mayo
shout out i'll be in your dm we enjoyed
a nice meal
as a family
what establishment the joseph ambler inn
okay in our neck of the woods nice i
don't know it delicious beautiful yeah
it was nice one of those old places you
know like like the blue belly or the
william penny or one you know like yeah
yeah old colonialist exactly that's
exactly what gotcha we did have a
private room
for that
we did
uh just order desserts and then just put
a candle in it we did sing happy
birthday because the kids are involved
private room also yep kids are involved
however what'd you do in this
conversation that we're having here yes
sparked a memory hit it that i may have
tried to bury oh boy that reflects
poorly on the foleys oh god i do believe
i do declare
that some special glasses were brought
some birthday glasses
and a request was made to the server hey
can you make these drinks in these
glasses these for her birthday what is a
birthday glass like a glam like a
plastic cup or a plastic glass with like
happy birthday plastic cup don't try to
class it up with plastic glass that's
counter-intuitive it might have had a
stem on it i'm not sure what it was cup
that said like happy birthday patty or
something something like that oh that
you got it like discountmugs.com where
we got our koozies that are available
check the link in the description that's
bad
that is trash i remember somebody asking
like i got plots that paddy's
birthday or what at paddy's party some
sort of trashy alliteration
hey i got plots at paddy's party
i remember that
we're gonna need said cup for the set by
the way cody's gonna need to wet her
beak on a cup i think we could probably
procure that
i would assume it's in one of the two
homes
i believe two homes either my brothers
or my mom's okay
yeah that's a tough look people that are
doing that are also doing the cake that
ain't good you brought them in and took
them out
yeah
oh maybe they did leave them there
no there's no way they left them there
what are you i'm gonna go over your
house for thanksgiving i'm gonna get one
[ __ ] dirtbags
i remember that when you went over to
your buddy's house to eat and they had
glasses that didn't match and all that
stuff like a worn down movies cup and
[ __ ] with all the paint got washed off
in the dishwasher i'm drinking a warm
pepsi out of a coffee mug
hey what's your name
yeah
not quite enough pepsi fits in a mug
that's about 15 minutes you need to get
through with sammy
if i'm eating pizza and you give me a
mug full of [ __ ] uh
i'm going straight up
shot glass yeah yeah that's not [ __ ]
look drinking soda out of a coffee mug
you only get like two tree cubes ice in
there too
talking about cakes i feel like we'd all
be in agreement on this that the
trashiest cake you could get is the one
where they print the photo on it
yes to me yes yes
if you're like unless you died
all right i'll give you that that's
still that's that that's dead guys but
still you died tragically yes of course
it wasn't your natural causes yeah you
died tragic dead guys cake to have that
cake if your face is ever printed on a
cake it didn't it was a closed castle if
i make sure
[Laughter]
if i die make sure they don't put my
face on anything i'd be happy okay i
don't want my face on anything like that
i don't want a t-shirt i don't want
nothing
i don't care what it is
definitely not a cake
because first of all they stink too and
it took them a couple years it's always
like who who wants to eat a dead guy's
ear
they got the eyeballs it took them a
couple of years because for a while they
were just like a thin sheet of paper
that was over it that you just ate and
pretended like you weren't eating
printer paper yeah it's not a [ __ ]
inkjet carrot cake
yeah that's tough
sorry your cake's all [ __ ] up we ran
out of toner i was gonna say extra toner
for me
why is this one in black and white we
ran out of magenta
yeah i uh
i'm not a big fan of that at all
no yeah you can't do that no you go
classic
i'll tell you what a classic
grocery store cake see we talked about
this with chrissy d mabu yeah [ __ ]
right up the middle
right up the middle i don't hate it
vanilla guys
that's all we ever got
that's all nobody ever went to my mom
made him my mom made him my mom would
make him too but like if we were buying
a cake especially like as we got older
my mom's like if i'm like
16 and we're just gonna like have like a
barbecue or whatever
she wasn't making a cake uh one because
i didn't like it so she would just buy
like a [ __ ] cheat cake chicken finger
cake
[Laughter]
ketchup icing
no ketchup until recently
um you weren't a ketchup kid at all
never
what did i know this i know you i've
just recently become a ketchup man i
know you were a barbecue guy what were
you dipping your fries in then
barbecue if it was there i'm a plain
jane really
old school meat and potatoes baby right
up the middle like angela's ashes
look at molly mcguire what do you think
what do you think the classiest cake is
black forest
listen
turn is my coffee
i don't know what the
the black forest is never [ __ ] good
and if you mention red velvet i'll smack
you it's the icing's good red get out of
here with the red velvet yeah it's it's
missing something yeah
it needs chocolate chips or something um
i don't know i'm not a cl i'm not a cake
guy i don't know something cake boss
makes tell you what i don't kick out of
bed is that confetti cake that shit's
hot what's that
you also know what's great though and it
is trashy we picked up one of those from
[ __ ] magnolia from my sister what the
[ __ ] the confetti cake
this guy well if you want to be a real
dirtbag about it it's funfetti yeah it's
funfetti a fun fatty cake
looks all right
they just put rainbow sprinkles in the
banner that's like milk bar [ __ ] yes
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] kite um a [ __ ]
old school right up the middle carvel
ice cream cake with the crumbles in the
in between the layers let it sit out for
a couple of minutes yeah let it rest
yeah eat it out of a bowl oh
not
but we used too
fight over them and as a kid
they were like salt in the ancient world
those crunchies when you were a kid bro
the [ __ ] wars were down in the crunch
we've secured the crunchy mine oh man
i'm telling you um
also too it was big when we were a kid
you know like 10 whatever uh was if we
were cutting the cake you would try to
get your name if it said like happy
birthday kevin or what he would try to
get your whole name
buddy sometimes you're eating a slice of
cake the size of the table this [ __ ]
munching on it you haven't put your
middle name in confirmation
[Laughter]
kevin james ryan kippy kj you put my
address on there as well
and p.o box yeah yeah my mom my mom
always made chocolate cake butter cream
icing homemade up the middle
[ __ ]
old school one of those waiting for me
on february when i [ __ ] walk into the
house after school
let's go yeah ready for dinner
um
all right let's do one more then we got
a skedaddle
um this one
is pretty funny and i i assume it
resonates with most suburban people this
is from michael lynn how many deflated
balls do you have in your garage dude
that's so [ __ ] funny you mentioned it
every dude there's something not i've
there's nothing at my mom's house that
you could play with no but there's
there's one of at least one of
everything dude that's so cool yesterday
sagalo and i had a catch with a football
of course you did that was in my that's
in my car that's my nephew's that is
[ __ ] half deflated yeah
no you never the pumps you never had
trying to find those needles when you
were a kid there was like a two-year
treasure there was a two-year period
where we had a tight ship at the house
really we had the air compressor
and all the needles and everything and
everything worked
and i you felt like [ __ ] richie rich
to get airplanes neighbors were coming
over let me use the i got the needle you
know what i mean oh those needles i
don't know what you it's like
do we not have dicks back then how come
we just didn't go and get something i
know they were never around i don't know
man there was a thing with the 90 at the
90s at least that for me i'm sure with
the 80s but like well i think we were
talking about this like you just
suffered you know what i mean you're
just like well i guess i'm just going to
play basketball with a flat ball yeah
now imagine a kid having that like i
don't know we just did everything with
whatever you had that was like so half
that yeah
never had new cars never had it was
always like you just never had a needle
for a [ __ ] pump never i know that
never
never how many times you shot a
basketball and just fell flat didn't
bounce back to you i think we were
talking about skippets and how the the
counter never works oh the counter never
worked on skip it's too scary to fix
that skip it what could you have fixed
that well i mean i'm not tim the tool
man tailor
i don't know my magnifying glass that's
what i'm saying i mean that's just
something that just didn't work the pump
you could get you could get a pump and
fix it you had to know someone at nasa
well then why weren't they why didn't
everybody have a pump they're nine bucks
now they weren't nine bucks back then
they had to be expensive that's what i'm
saying like it didn't make sense that
not everybody else had a working pump
everybody's got one now probably they
probably come with cars every trunk
probably comes with a [ __ ] air
compressor
hmm yeah
good times
all right let's do one more because that
really slow that really died
looking at the host to [ __ ] land the
plane he pulls up
let's npr this for a minute
this one's just funny this is from
michelle i haven't had a question read
yet what is the trashy trashiest chip
and why is it cool ranch doritos
she's not wrong
they're good love a nice cool ranch they
are
the pinnacle they are phenomenal they're
good
they're great they're not my favorite
doritos really no what are you sweet
chili lime guy not too bad like a new
money [ __ ]
out of here spicy not doing nothing to
turn your nose up at either okay you
bite your [ __ ] tongue cool ranch is
great it's fine but you're an up to
middle straight nacho cheese guy
[ __ ] screaming cold coke those things
hit the scene like a [ __ ] tidal wave
big fan baby
let's wrap it up let's wrap it up gang
listen we love you guys we appreciate
you uh come out and see a live show yeah
some couple of dates for the end of the
year it's gonna be fun upstate new york
albany syracuse and hartford connecticut
will be uh in the middle of december so
get those [ __ ] tickets the link will
be in the description and we'll probably
be in the bumper already and come to see
us in new york city baby we love you
we'll see you next week peace